Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"Worst Summer Job" stories
from you guys. Here we go.
This first one's from
@emcubedcreative. She says...
-"Yeah!"
-"I know her!"
All right.
-"That's my baby!"
-"Stop it, Dad."
This one's from @jbest3435.
He says...
"I just saved your life.
All right. Cool.
Okay, you, stand up.
Saved your life.
Why is everybody drowning?
Just stand up."
-"Shark!"
-"There's a shark in the pool!
Shark, stand up!"
Yeah, yeah.
This one's from @v-i-price.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
Oh, he could have lied.
-What? That's not true. Come on.
-That's cold-blooded.
-That's cold, man.
I worked at Abercrombie.
-Did you really?
-Yeah, I was a stockroom boy.
[ Tuba plays sad notes ]
I really was, yeah.
That was before
they sold out, man.
-Before they came dark...
-That's the reason why, right?
-Yeah, that's exactly -- you got
a front-of-store face.
[ Laughs ]
-I appreciate that.
I got a job there
because me and my buddy --
Me and my college roommate,
we both got it
because if you work there
you get a free shirt
and a free pair of jeans.
And so I said,
"If we both work there,
you get a different shirt
and a different pair of jeans,
and I'll get a different --
Then we can just wear -- That's
our clothes for the week."
-Swap it out.
-And so we kind of
built the store,
and we stocked it
and everything like that
and folded everything.
I hate folding everything. Ugh!
If could I just ask
for one thing, world peace.
Second thing, don't unfold
anything at a store.
-Yeah.
-It is the worst thing.
-Did you have a folder board?
-It's just like --
A folder board.
But that doesn't make it easier.
You understand what --
They're jeans.
Why do you have to
unfold it for?
Unless you're trying it.
"Uh, this shirt looks good."
"Yeah, it does.
Now I got to refold it."
This one's from @Mollie-Galvez.
She says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I love you, Grandma!"
-"I made these myself!"
-"I'm teaching my sweet
granddaughter how to swindle!"
Okay.
This one's from @laurieraney.
She says...
That sounds fantastic.
-That sounds great.
Like a new TV show.
-This one's from
@MobsterLobsterr.
He says...
-"What are you doing
to the boy?!
Get in here, Joshua!
Making him stand out there
and yell at birds all day!
That's not right." Yeah.
This one's from @km-belland.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's the winner right there.
-That's the winner. A bison.
-This last one's from
@Kataztrophie. She says...
There you go. Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.